so here I have the muscle hanging from a  motor that I can  insert twist into the fiber with  then I have a weight hanging now this  weight is 20 grams and that actually  works very well for this fiber what I  can do now is just put something here to  keep it from untwisting and turn the  motor on and as I do that the motor is  going to insert twist into the fiber and  now it's begun coiling and you can see  the weight is raising pretty quickly now  the fiber is now forming coils so the  coils are much more compact and so it's  raising the weight to shorten the length  of the fiber or the muscle  so this is just a normal heat gun and  now when I heat it it starts to contract